[Music]
the careers of these young Turkish
soccer talents are intimately tied up
with goose ball football clubs goats how
come to cover the club's expenses goose
war sells goat milk and for every youth
player sold to a major club more goats
are purchased this unconventional
business model was dreamt up by goose
for club president Kenan boo you click
maybe we recently sold 18 talented youth
players to major Turkish football clubs
for an equivalent of 22 hundred euros we
invested this money in 10 new goats our
animals produce up to one thousand
liters of high-quality milk per year the
milk guarantees goose ball football club
a steady income in economically
difficult times
[Music]
goose boar is based in the Western
Turkish city of Sparta Kenan view club
Libby is proud of his club with its
history going back more than 60 years
many national players started their
careers here in humble beginnings even
so nobody here believes goose paw will
ever make it to turkey's top football
division that's why the club shifted his
attention to training young talents to
prepare them for professional football
careers with big soccer clubs in places
like Ankara and Istanbul
Honaker they trained with us
between the ages of 11 and 19 they need
to hone their skills until they're 17
and at 19 we sell them off to other
clubs for which goose ball football club
then buys more goats selling goat meat
or milk allows the club to invest in new
football jerseys or to renew the soccer
pitch goose balls youngsters don't seem
to mind being traded for goats not a bad
idea really when I'm sold off and they
buy goats that in turn benefits younger
players at our club that way they'll
think fondly of me when I'm not here
anymore
goose ball club president Kenan Buchla
blabby is pleased with his scheme he
hopes the animals will quickly reproduce
and that the price of goat needs and
milk will rise HBU clearly be wants to
triple the size of the goat herd in five
years time that means the young talents
are learning more than just playing
football they learn about the worth of
the animals and the work of farmers in
that sense we're teaching them valuable
environmental lessons as well
goose ball football club shows that
livestock farming and football can go
together pretty well and goose paws
youngsters learn an important lesson
concerning sustainability so who knows
maybe someday other scores will be
inspired to emulate this unusual
business model
[Music]